herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute ich stehe heute bei mir in der
küche ich hab mal ausnahmsweise nicht
mein leben im keller getauscht sondern
ich habe was übertrieben und cool ist
für mich vorbereitet man heute gespräche
gehabt hätten dann rechne ich hatte
selbst nicht damit gerechnet die stand
genau hier mit nike und jana und habe
gesagt ich habe ein video idee und
michael meinte diese die ihr leben musst
du mit amber und meinte ich schon
erzählt
ich weiß dass wir etwas kitschiges
machen immer liegt käse und ich hab das
heutige video eine käse pistole selbst
käse oder käse käse eigentlich ein käse
verkehr
diese pistole worum geht's das ist das
gute stück von boula dass sie auch
wirklich genau so aus wie eine
heißklebepistole schon mit durchgehender
muss als erstes dieses ding herausziehen
komplett dann kann man hier vorne die
tube befüllen jetzt erstmal die
kartusche da drüben mit käse
das ist nicht wenig ist sie zu einem
runden doch doch ich glaube ich übergebe
dir mal die aufgabe ich schließe der
zwischenzeit schon mal die pistole an
weil die muss logischerweise vorhalten
gar nicht so einfach wenn man so große
teile dieses oder allgemein geklärt zu
sein meinen jetzt allerdings muss sagen
nach 56 jahren privat machst das jetzt
nicht mehr so aber wenn du sagst dass du
gerne
der tief ist dann ist die challenge
league auf jeden fall ob die fürbitte
für die challenge habe ich nämlich dass
hier besorgen ich werde mir nicht
gleichwertiges wurde vorgeheizt ist
zwischen uns beiden eine trennwand
packen dann klickt jeder fünf minuten
mit der maschine und wir müssen
irgendwas krasses bauen mit der
kehrmaschine etwas bauen unsere chancen
sich hinaus wächst und gedeiht kann man
ist unsere der weiß perfekt maxi diesen
käse ich finde dieser krise ist so
richtig pervers das bauen einer kurzen
und langen starten hier
warum ein gewisser weise richtig cool
war obwohl auskommt und dort bleibt frei
oh mein gott
leute ich bin halt wir haben jetzt weiß
was von solchen mix boxen doch alle
möglichen sachen drin
wir überlegen uns jetzt beide was wir
machen wollen und dann geht's los
das ist
wir haben echt richtig viele mögen da
habe ich hier noch über das spiel
deutschland
benutzen sie die blase die leser ist
dann der ganze auch essen kann danach
nash ich glaube es reicht erstmal so
weiter
ich habe glaube ich eine ganz andere
idee als er nur als es würde mich
wundern wenn er mal die gleiche idee hat
wie ich aber ich glaube meine idee ist
natürlich deutlich besser jetzt ist es
halt ganz kurz glaube werde ich das
machen jetzt ganze gerne wenn ich das
jetzt machen könnten die ersten ist
vielleicht schon checken welche richtung
das gehen
ich bin eigentlich absolut unkreativ
sowas so was für kunst angeht und
sonders aber ich habe echt grün idee
eigentlich wie läuft's bei dir da drin
machst du das ganze denken dass ich
würde mir ist es karten bei mir
irgendwas ich wende mich manchmal eins
ist klar ich mache meinen für eine
stabile und dennoch denn
wir gucken wir gerne wahr
die beiden wissen wie viel hast du von
deinem von einem projekt glaub ich hab
so auf 20 prozent ich habe die pistole
p8 sind oft geschaut hast du geil
es ist ein glück die herausgeschossen
kommt mein gott wo ich habe die beste
idee
ich werde es niemals essen können ich
bin so stolz darauf ich bin stolz darauf
ist auf alles was ist sondern eben
jemand was man kunst zu nehmen bei denen
natürlich nun vorstellt das so riecht
gut weil ich war also meiner meinung
nach jetzt kam auch auf die lehrer diese
staaten haben sich nach 1 nicht
ich hatte ein einziges mal hat nicht nur
kunst nein das war ein der oberstufe und
deshalb hatte das lag daran dass der
trick dass wir ein abstraktes abstrakt
ist projekt haben wurde
ich habe meine idee es war noch mal ein
bisschen geändert ich hoffe das hält so
ich hätte mich das jetzt das kühlsystem
wir werden sie bereits tätig zum
nachbilden vor du wärst gemacht hat das
gut geklappt dass du dir so gewollt hast
einfach per macht demnach die
konzentrierte ist sehen wir mal was
gewinnen das ist so richtig weiß was es
ist aber irgendwie sie sehr
eindrucksvoll aus und aus architekt das
beste auto im feld
ich sage noch nichts das klingt so
natürlich viel besser aussehen oder vier
schwestern hand
wirklich wirklich gut damit arbeiten
also ja ich hätte gedacht das ist viel
schwerer ist natürlich auch das gefühl
habe viel mächtiger schlag
dort stand also dass wir so schmutzig
werden aber das ist wirklich keine
schlacht filme hier einmal nach immer
hat es natürlich garten zeitlichen
vorteil wenn ich jetzt hier nach für
immer wie weit bist du da drüben jetzt
nur etwa 80 prozent ohne job die beste
idee meint glaube ich richtig cool
bormann ich habe dich mit was man noch
sorgen diesem raumschiff sei aber er
wird ihn und ich habe auch keinen keiner
großen anspannung läuft dazu sagen weil
ich werde wie gesagt nicht besonders gut
wenn du sehr viel sage ist kann man das
ist nun anders erklären ja kleinen
projekt werden haben wir ja auch dabei
wenn man hat das kann mainz weder
erkennen noch erklärt ich kann man
glaube ich bekennen
die schreibung zeitlich gut sind wir
sind brüder
spätestens jetzt müsst ihr auch mal ein
und wollte mal vorbeischauen
bei den disney crazies den videos aber
ich hab gar nicht mit wenn ihr eine
gepachtet anstand hat eine kurve
flimmert schreibt keine kommentare ob
wir jetzt schon erkennen können was ich
hier vor aber das würde mich
interessieren wird nicht gestört und
denkt würden wir denken dass man das
erkennen danone wird wenn ich kinder
hätte dass so eine coole geschäft ja
oder wenn die tiefe befindet eine kinder
aktiv
es ist nicht mögen das casino ist nein
es geht alles kaputt was ich hoffe ich
habe die zeit gekommen
alles geht kaputt schon klappen am
anfang ja über dir läuft richtig da drin
oder komm jetzt kommen jetzt komplett
trommelt com mit das ist ganz weg ich
glaube es bald ganz geschafft ist
geschafft habt ihr okay kennt ihn ja das
ist richtig
auch in der nacht wird stimmt das und
sehnsucht
so macht man das heutzutage leute jetzt
ist das hier hin und man konnte heute
fällt wirklich der krise wird immer
stärker
ja also das wird nicht wieder die
weisheiten nachhaltiger je höher desto
besser nämlich richtige feinst arbeitet
hier etwas stresst das lagerfeuer
boah das ist so cool etwaig wird so
stolz warten ich war wirklich noch nie
so stolz auf irgendetwas in meinem leben
und ich glaube das hat uns wirklich auf
den ersten blick erkennen wenn man jetzt
wirklich etwas spannendes zu bieten hat
ich würde sagen ich bin fertig ich gehe
jetzt noch eine minute zeit
ich bin so schnell ich bin so gespannt
das duo vorbereitet sagt er war okay
leute
wir haben es geschafft ist ein jahr
ich bin auch ich würde sagen jetzt
müssen nicht nur benutzt sich unfair zu
meistern betont macht war das nächste
ziel schon papier heißt es sei okay
steinheims verband dass sein papier
steht am abgrund und schnee verloren
dass ich jetzt mal ein bisschen was ich
bin ein guter gastgeber immer das tier
ausgemacht das erste chance erkennen
guck mal ja ein bisschen kokett erst
eine kurze und das ist so herzer
software frei geworden was ist das für
immer verwehrt
ich hätte gesagt das ist ein
aber das hier ist sehr eindrucksvoll
also heute nicht besser und was ist das
ich hätte gesagt das ist so zieht
kriegen vielleicht und da drin ist eine
indianer familie
er endet das indianerzelt offen floss
bei meiner parsberg
man muss dazu sagen aber ich habe etwas
langweiliges gemacht was schon geht und
er aber das hindert aber wenn ich mich
ja schon so was großes team den super
hier rede rede und lenkrad und alle
komponenten sind ja was ich habe gesehen
hat so ein schild in der mittelzone
kommt wird gewählt wir zeigen euch jetzt
einen karpfen und einen tipp auf einem
floß pommern
[Musik]
ich wollte aber wir vielleicht
entscheidet also erstmal vom ausfüllen
hiervon personen also man kennt mich
auch als dem professionellen kerze
pistor in skulpturen ist das ist erich
man muss natürlich beachten dass max
ihren kleinen heimvorteil fertig habe
ich natürlich ein paar gedanken zu
gemeinschaft jeder folgen erst jetzt
zeigen warum es überhaupt diese ich
wollte erst ein haus bauen danach nicht
mehr so dass das ist einfach reifen da
muss ich natürlich sofort einschreiten
also man muss schon sagen max autoklav
ist ein bisschen keine akten gearbeitet
dafür ist es aber um einiges spezieller
gemeint hat ist er hat sich was neues
überlegt freunde es ist schwierig ich
glaube ich bin ich bin back ups trotz
seiner wunderbaren frau als käse hätte
die geldinstitute werden selbst die 50
grad wollen wir jetzt einfach das ist so
schlimm weil wir so stoppt wollen wir
einfach die dinger nicht rein wollten
das machen oder das ist dann lasse ich
hätte da zusammen wenn man es hoch hebt
das ist mein kettcar bei mir auch gut
also dass es nur aufgestellt werden
die kommunisten käse macht wird das
rezept ein gras warum geil so leute das
war's auch ich habe heute gebäude
vielleicht ist er jetzt die aus
zurückstellen irgendwann mal der branche
herausfordernd wer war s check auch
unbedingt etwas letztes video update
teenagern luxus essen probieren lassen
sehr interessant generell nachdem
richtig neueste videos deshalb jackson
league in dem schreiben ab es war
wirklich cool dass die rede war richtig
coole videos sehr gerne und dann sehen
uns vom nächsten video wieder fit ist